hey everybody is Jessie a little bit
later today than I normally am so sorry
for everybody who you know won't be able
to see this hopefully you can least
catch the recording but maybe it might
be better for some people because
instead of coming in at the end of my
normal 2 o'clock train you'll be at the
beginning of the stream today that's at
4:30 Eastern Time it's really hot in my
office so I do have a fan running let me
know if that's making a lot of noise if
it's annoying I'll turn it off it's not
like unbearably hot so I can stand to
turn it off today I'm gonna start out by
showing some of the issues that I had
yesterday that I was able to fix and
I'll show you those had a few like
little design changes for the the
resource page basically I implemented a
lot of what we had talked about
yesterday
and and then I'm going to show you what
I'm doing with the API calls so we're
gonna do I'm basically going to be
trying to pull in as much of the content
as I possibly can from the WordPress API
so that the when I'm done with this
project they'll be like really no need
for anyone to contact me and the people
in charge of the content for the site
will be able to handle all that content
so assuming that nothing like really
crazy happens with the site I should be
able to just just let it go off on its
own which that'll be good I really like
working on this I learned a lot of stuff
but I am ready to move on it's nice to
it's nice to start over with a clean
slate and be able to try to do even
better than last time
all right so I'm just going to check
okay great we got our view count is up
to a decent amount I always hate to get
like right into it before people have
had a chance to to join in and I know
that this was really late notice I think
I I posted on Twitter about it like five
minutes maybe four minutes before I was
going to stream so they'll probably be
some people joining in late because they
didn't see it but I'm gonna check the
live chat hey hi hey everyone a lot of
people saying hi okay so Anthony says
there's just a little bit of background
noise not that bad
okay so cool yeah let me know if it if
it does end up being bad so like I'm
actually the fan is sitting it's kind of
blowing directly on the microphone so I
am gonna move it a bit and then that
should cut down on the noise and I know
uh you know wind can makes really bad
noise on a microphone so I don't want
the same thing to happen here Anthony
says I started front-end course two
weeks ago and I finished algorithm today
yeah all right way to go that glad to
hear that you're you're getting through
some of this stuff keep me up-to-date if
you can in the live chat I'd love to to
hear about more about your progress and
that's yeah Sarah said Mike's catch
everything yeah it definitely it does so
just I'm like turn it off after a little
while anyway it actually has done a
decent job of getting thing called
getting things cooled down a bit so the
reason I didn't stream at my normal time
listen because I had a meeting the
meeting I might have been able to get in
like a really really short stream in and
still make it to the meeting but I
didn't want to try to you know do a
really short stream
and have it not be kind of like as good
as normal I probably would have had time
to do any questions or anything so I
thought I'd better just a postpone it I
plan on working late today anyway
so so this this should work out I kind
of thought I'd be able to get out of the
meeting so that's why I didn't I didn't
post earlier about the time change but
then like right before maybe like within
an hour before the normal extreme time I
learned that I I was I had to go to the
meeting so that's why I was kind of late
notice okay well let me show you
Jordan says moving the fan didn't change
the sound sounds like you're sitting in
a server rooms let me let me turn the
fan I can actually turn it down
I'll try turning it down a little bit
right now and then if I have to I can
turn it off completely I also do have
another computer on that I don't
normally have one so and it's kind of
noisy as well I don't know how it turned
on I thought I had it off maybe I just
had it asleep but I do never like a
really old Windows laptop that I keep
around just in case I need it so I I
almost never need it because I use a
browser stack for testing now but before
I had that it did come in handy for
testing things okay cool
so it seems like that sounds better now
that the fans turned on all right so let
me start showing you a little bit about
what's changed since yesterday what's
been updated the development site let me
put the link I forgot to put the link in
the description for the show so let me
find the link now and
you know I'll post it here we go have a
lot of stuff open
so here's the link to we now have a
development server so normally before I
was just doing everything locally which
is okay but you weren't able to actually
interact with the site near the latest
version of the site before it really
went live unless you clone the git repo
and ran it you know locally on your
machine so I had already had another
droplet already set up and ready from
when we were testing the load balancing
and I never I never shut that droplet
down so I had always planned on using it
as a development server at some point so
that is up and running now so you can
check out the IP address if if I forget
to put it in the the video and you're
watching this later on the IP address is
1 6 2 dot 3.2 for 3.8 6.67 oh it's not
working again it keeps stopping so it's
right now I'm not running it with from
from p.m. to
and so it's possible that I just need to
set that up it's probably not gonna do
it right now
there you go so
I'm gonna start it up again alright it
should be working now so I'm gonna try
to refresh my page in my other screen
okay it is working out I just didn't
take the time to set it up in a more
reliable way because at first I was only
using it just to just to test a few
things out but since then I had requests
from other people to work here to see
the site so now I probably ought to set
it up in a better way
push-push Pinder asks about is it
possible to get the live session on the
weekend the recording will be available
so you can definitely check out the
recording I probably won't do another
live session on the weekend but the
recording is definitely available so
it'll be right here on the free code
camp channel there's actually a playlist
for all the streams so if you don't see
it on like the main page you can check
the playlist is just called live coding
with Jesse but if you're gonna view it
you know sometimes the next day or two
it'll probably one of the first videos
up on the main page
okay
all right so let me show you now you can
see the site now and actually I don't
have it looks like I don't have the the
very latest stuff but so I'll bring the
latest stuff up on my screen
okay see I was wondering where am i when
my browser window went so went here I
think I have it the site up somewhere
else so let's pull it over and now I
can't find it
oh well not a problem just go to
localhost okay so nothing new so yeah
nothing new there on the about page
figures my dev server needs to be
started again I never bothered to figure
out why my dev server always needs
restarted and only on this computer I
can run the same same stuff on my other
computers and it works so anyway so on
this page it doesn't look like much has
changed but all of this data is now
being pulled in from the wordpress api
so all the text with the exception of I
think this title is still hard-coded and
the image you can see I need to work on
the formatting a bit I think WordPress
is automatically wrapping this in a P
tag and so it's messing up the
formatting so I'll have to I'll have to
account for that it'll probably be
easier just to account for that in the
code then to try to change how WordPress
does things because sometimes I do want
them to actually use wrap things in P
tags but sometimes I don't the only
visible change here other than that kind
of mistake is I'm actually pulling in
the the test pages now the data before I
had just made some lists just just to
see how it would look now I'm actually
pulling this in so when we click it the
link works and it goes to our page it's
still just test data but hopefully we'll
get some real data in there and be able
to kind of get a better idea of how it
looks and on our resources page this is
where we have the biggest change so I
switched up from the black which you can
see on the dev site right now
so I had the black before and I've
switched it to the red the red
background with it has like this semi
transparent background image kind of
going across here and then now you know
everything's white the check marks end
up being like that gold color that's on
the site so I'm not sure if I like it
being gold what I might end up switching
it back to white but for now I think the
gold is okay
so before some of this stuff was gray
but it just doesn't look very good
against the red so I did I got some
feedback yesterday from you all and I
got some feedback from some of the
people involved in the project here
where I work and general consensus was
going with the red would probably be
better so with the red and then I
increased the padding a bit just to kind
of it looked really weird with this
background image when it was shorter so
that's why I increased the padding a bit
but basically everything still functions
the same way so everything works I
didn't get a chance to check this out on
multiple browsers so we did have a an
issue open up on github based on what we
saw in the stream yesterday and that was
that on some browsers especially windows
browsers one of them in Windows this
this doesn't look right so I'll still
have to check that out on some browsers
but I didn't want to do it if I was
gonna change a lot of the colors anyway
I wanted to wait until I changed it
before I tried to troubleshoot that so
that's something I'll be doing soon or
that's something that's that's open for
for anybody to you know try out if you'd
like to and submit a pull request I did
have a pull request that I pulled in
from Bill so let me show you I'll be
I'll show you and I'll explain to you so
since I've only pulled it in on the dev
branch I don't think he shows up yet
in the official like contributors page
but basically bills contributions were
pretty nice and that he I didn't have a
unique ID a unique key for each of these
which you need and reactor it gives you
an error message it still loads it but
within the console you get an error
message in dev tools and then he added
this is actually a horizontal rule now
before we had a black bottom border now
this is an HR and with some shadows and
gradients and things going on actually I
think this is how do you do is I think
this was a background gradient so I only
changed what bill sent in just a bit so
I just lightened it a bit I checked out
the material design documentation on how
to do lists and they're lines between
the lists are very light so I decided to
go with that since we're kind of trying
to follow material design principles
here and also he put in a little bit of
code to make sure that the last in the
list the last element in the list
doesn't have an HR at the bottom so
that's it not not a whole lot happening
I didn't get to do quite as much work as
I had hopes because I had meetings like
kind of unexpected meetings this morning
that lasted lasted a while but it was
good I guess we'll get feedback for this
site so it worked out alright so I'm
gonna move this over because I don't
really need it right now
we'll leave this here so we can keep
referring back to it but I want to show
you let me uh organize this a bit better
here we go but I want to show you the
about page and how I pulled in the the
data and actually let me check the live
chat I had an idea so normally I use a
Pomodoro timer so you use this and I
thought I should I'm gonna start using
this timer now and that way if it goes
off it'll be a reminder for me to check
the live chat so I don't forget so
hopefully I'll check it you know before
it goes off but just in case you know at
least every 25 minutes I'll check it and
then that'll give me just a little
reminder of how long these things are
taking because I usually forget to
record how long things take during my
streaming so let me check back in the in
the chat here okay not a whole lot going
on the chat hey Sebastian how's it going
but my employer is now in the live chat
Franciscan University Steubenville it's
not it's it's actually the the guy that
works in the office right next to me he
must just be logged into the Franciscan
University YouTube account so he told me
that my mom was online too but instead
of he's just kidding
okay so John says thin light thin border
lines are easiest by using one pixel
inset and a very light gray okay cool I
might try that I am I kind of just went
with what what bill had for this and
just lightened it a bit but if I get a
chance maybe I'll try to you know change
it even more I wouldn't mind it being a
bit thinner I mean I think this I think
this looks fine to me but but a little
bit thinner probably would match more
with what's in the material design
documentation so so thanks for that I'm
like I'm kind of getting down to the
wire here so I'm only gonna work on
things that are absolutely necessary but
I can see like I'm I'm a little bit
confident now that I can get done what I
need to get done before the 20th and
then I'll switch to another project but
it seems like I'm gonna be able to get
things done I say that knowing that I
usually run into unforeseen issues that
take longer so assuming that I don't run
into too many of those should get
everything done then I won't have to
work crazy hours all right so I'm gonna
show you what I gonna show you all the
about page I have the music I'm playing
in my headphones is from Spotify
throwbackthursday playlist and this week
it's on 90s music and so if you grew up
in the 90s like I did it will be
nostalgic for you
I find myself remembering like lots of
stuff that happened in middle school in
grade school that I associate with these
songs alright so
at the top here before so as of
yesterday I wasn't pulling any data in
for this page it was all coded directly
into this component now I'm gonna pull
in more data so the big problem that
I've been wrestling with and I've
mentioned it a few times on the in the
live stream is that I needed a way to
get multiple data from multiple
different post types in one API call so
I needed it to be here because I wanted
anything in here gets rendered on the
server so the API call will actually get
made on the server and everything will
get rendered and then the data will get
sent to the client as an HTML page and
then it can also be made when you do
client-side routing so the same call
could be made on the client the problem
was when I tried to write some code to
do multiple calls inside here
I always got errors it's possible that
there's a way to do it and I just I just
couldn't figure it out
so I found another way there's a plugin
for the WordPress for WordPress that
exposes this endpoint this multiple post
type endpoint and then you can say what
types of posts you want so right now I
want the PDF page post type and then I
want just the page post type I didn't
want to do this because you can't if you
specify parameters for you know for how
you want to narrow this data down the
parameters apply to every post type so
it's not that useful because certain
post types have different they have
different data that's coming through and
I have different needs to the post type
so what I'm gonna have to do to make
this work is this is fine but I'm now
going to end up getting more data
I would normally need and it should work
for most pages the only pages where it's
going to be a little bit tough is if I
happen to have a page that has a lot of
different data I might not get it all
with this hundred per page thing and
that's that's the WordPress limit you
can't easily get more than 100 posts per
page and I don't have time to try to
work around that so probably what will
end up happening is everything that's
essential that I really want to be
rendered on the server will be in this
first API call and then if there's other
things that should be rendered later on
they can be rendered later on I'll
render it in another API call so usually
it'll be based on a user interaction and
that's fine so then upon that
interaction it'll make the call and and
that should be fine it should work if
for some reason there's a page where
there's some data that just needs to
display and there's no user interaction
I can make it happen on a scroll so
perhaps if a user gets like halfway down
the page then I'll make the call and
load the stuff at the bottom of the page
it should work out none of the pages
right now are so big that it won't work
but today I'm actually gonna do some of
this I'm kind of showing you how I did
it first and then I'm gonna do it on
some pages so we'll find out if it'll
work for all the pages but since I did
that the API call I get back has all the
PDF pages and all the page post types
and so down here I started doing things
like for the intersection I made a page
in WordPress called about intro so I'm
grabbing the the page that has about
interest I'm using filter and then I'm
I'm rendering the content of that page
inside this this column div so I've had
to move the float X class up here to the
column instead of having it on the P tag
which is fine because I don't want the
person entering things in WordPress to
have to worry about any code so why
don't you just be able to use the the
WYSIWYG in WordPress which will
automatically add
eat eggs but it won't automatically add
the classes we want one thing I didn't
know about is I use the map here just
because I was copy and pasting some
stuff I was doing elsewhere there's only
one post that I really want so I'm not
sure if I have to use map so if there's
a better way to do this where I can just
grab this right from filter and use it
let me know if anybody knows it if not
I'm I'm not really gonna take the time
to look it up right now because this
works and this is okay because if I ever
have to grab more than one post type and
render it it's already set up to be able
to handle that but for now this is the
sodus you see I've done that for each
section so let me show you let's go back
to the about page just to see so each
section is now its own page in WordPress
and I can show you what it looks like in
WordPress as well so in WordPress if we
go to pages see I have about intro
that's the top part the about quote
banner is down here section 2 section 3
so that's what I'm gonna do the only
things that aren't on there right now
these I didn't put in they're not
editable in these for now I don't think
I'm going to put them in because the
odds of these changing are really small
so there's not really high turn over
here at the university especially for
the upper level positions you know once
people get up there they stay there
forever until they're ready to retire
also I'm not sure that these will change
soon enough so if I have time later on
maybe I'll do this but for now I think
it's okay to keep these hard-coded
because for these I would have to
probably have to make custom post types
so it's a little bit more work than just
an extra page so I want to make a custom
post type for this you know kind of bio
card and then iterate over that
render it and then the same thing here
it would be a custom post type for these
collaborator cards so I don't want to do
all that for those sections right now
since they're not likely to change but I
want to check out we'll start with the
home page and we'll just check out my
service topic this is driving me crazy
if I had only just took like you know 15
minutes a month ago to fix this when it
first happened I wouldn't have to worry
about this and I still I still never
take the time all right so on the home
page I'm gonna leave all this up here
hard-coded this is not likely to change
and I really don't want it to change
because all of the spacing and
everything on all the screen sizes is
pretty exact if someone went in here and
changed this and made it a lot bigger or
something it it would mess everything up
so don't want that to change
the video for now I'm gonna leave it
like this at some point it might not be
a bad idea to have a page with a custom
field that was just the embed code for
this video to be able to change it but
for now I think it's it's okay like that
I want to make these their own custom
post type so we'll definitely be pulling
in we're gonna make the post type for
this and then pull in the data the the
image for this is gonna change but I
don't think I'm gonna take the time to
put it in here if I'm gonna make this
editable from WordPress then we'll see
maybe the person in charge of the
content will do that the person in
charge of the content and her name is
Amy
I always just keep saying the person in
charge of the content but it's much
shorter to just say Amy so Amy is gonna
put
probably put the the new image in I can
show you the image though this is it's
going to be this image so which will
work well because then the the title
will go down here and this section will
be darkened a bit so it's perfect image
too to put the title there it won't
really block anything this section which
I've already made a page for this
section will be editable I'm glad Google
Calendar let me know that today is
garbage day or tomorrow is garbage day
so I need to put the garbage out today
so glad for that reminder and then these
will be pulled in from the API as well
so we're gonna have three three
different sections so we're going to
need three different post types this
will be a from the page post type this
will be from I guess we'll call this the
formation cards yeah I'm not sure what
else to call them right now but the
formation card post type and this will
come from the the news or the blog
actually we won't need to make a new
post type because I'm gonna pull these
from there just the normal posts that
are built in to WordPress so that should
be okay as is and if I have time I may
change how these look but I think
they're okay right now I just don't like
that I've like kind of made them all
have a max height and there's all this
space but I'm not sure I'll have time to
really do what I need to to make them
look how I want them to look all right
so let's go in and work on this I'll
connect this up first and these because
I already have the post types made and
then I'll decide whether or not I
actually want to make a new post type
during the stream or not let me know in
the live chat if you'd like to see me
create a post site but I've already done
it a few times so you may not even want
to see
again it doesn't take very long but may
not be very interesting all right
oops not moose no is there some setting
that I can edit so that the my Mac
doesn't automatically change the order
of my my desktops like that's for some
reason it always does that and I don't
like it I have them in the order that I
want them in alright so we need to find
our home pages are the index page and
make it slightly bigger check this so
I'm gonna grab the about page and move
it over I have so much going on here
let me get rid of some of these things
serious like such changes no I don't
think I changed it no okay so oh you
know what I had I just occurred to me I
had one other error that kept happening
at the end and I didn't show you how I
fixed that error so the error was that
every time I tried to go to one of those
single pages that the PDF pages that we
were linking to from the about page I
would get an error about the side nav
init function and I figured out what the
problem was the problem was that in the
layouts so in in the layout components I
didn't have these two dots here so it
was just going to static jazz app
touches which was fine normally it was
working normally
for some reason when it was coming from
one of those pages that we were using
the parameterised routing for it just
wasn't working so the reason it I didn't
catch it before was because the the one
page that I was looking off of that did
work was he wasn't using the layout it
was using the old style of how we did
this so anyway that's all I had to fix
and it fixed everything so it took a
while to figure it out but it was an
easy fix once once I did all right so
now I'm going to take the about page and
move it over here so that we can copy
and paste some stuff if we need to and I
do want to copy and paste this it's not
really fun to type out so we want to hit
that end point that multiple post type
end point that we get from the plug-in
and we're gonna need we don't need PDF
page when you post
I think post is the post type we'll see
in a second we either get the data we
want and then we want page we haven't
made that other post type yet so I'm not
I'm going to try to get it because we'll
get an error and I can check this right
away to see if it worked by going into
dev tools for the site and we can go
into the react dev tools screen and
we'll see our props up here oops we're
getting an empty objects I did something
wrong so let me maybe I need to say
posts which I it again
hmm
still not get anything all right so I'm
gonna just grab this and we'll try it
out right in the browser
hmm not getting anything
okay we should have gotten something on
that first time
oops I grabbed the wrong site it ought
to it auto-filled this other site which
I also built in a similar way okay so
this is better so this is giving us what
we need
I'm not sure why it didn't work the
first time I did it let's try it again
and I'm gonna manually refresh this it's
possible it was just a refresh problem
there we go and now we have everything
safe - props and we can filter things by
its type if we need to or filter by
anything we want but for the news part
we're gonna filter by post and then
we're gonna filter secondarily by we
have a custom field where's our custom
field ID so why our type inside this
advanced custom field okay I'm gonna
check the lights out again it's been a
while this timer actually is really
helping me to remember how long it's
been
d 404 says just arrived welcome also
after you use the fetch API to get your
data I do I do tests or I do use the
fetch API so I recommend using it if you
haven't tried it yet definitely try it
out it's way easier than any other
method I've ever used to make API calls
and don't worry about the browser
support just use the polyfill so as long
as you use the polyfill you should be
fine on most modern browsers it even
works on it works on Internet Explorer
11 so definitely it's definitely worth
learning it'll save you time it's just
so much more simple I really like it a
lot better then do the other ways of
making API calls with you know Ajax or
you know just like a plain xhr request
Sebastian asks what do you need tested
on edge ok the yeah the drop down the
the select input on the resources page
was acting weird if you check out the
the github repo there's an issue open
for that
okay so Sarah Sarah tested her on
Firefox and it looks fine on Firefox
that's awesome but it looks like she
said Opera and Chrome on on windows are
not it's like waiting out everything so
I have to test that out
okay yeah if you want to see it in
action I did put a link in so maybe for
everyone that's come in a little bit
later on I'll put the link in the live
chat again for the dev server hopefully
it's working and it didn't quit working
again okay it's still working so should
be able to go there
okay blad says just landed here why does
jessie have a timer running it's a
Pomodoro timer which I usually run this
all the time when I'm working and I
record how long it takes me to do
everything I record that in my Trello
board so you can check out my Trello
board I just not realised I have my
calendar up here so I've been showing
everyone everything I'm doing all month
so I hope there's nothing embarrassing
up there
and it's not as my wife's calendar on
there too so I really don't have a good
idea of what's on there because she
could have put anything in there so
maybe I'll have to move that to another
screen for future streams or just get
rid of it maybe that's better I'll just
headaches it out of anyway so like these
numbers that are on my Trello board and
there's a link to my Trello board in the
description if you want to check it out
these are like the dark numbers or how
many plummeted or cycles I estimate that
a task will take and then the greyed out
ones or the the slightly transparent
ones are how long it actually has taken
me so this is really helpful for me to
be able to like I can go back in and see
how long things took me before it's
helpful for being able to accurately
estimate future projects how much time
it will take me and it is helpful as
well for me to remember just to take a
break because otherwise I would just
keep working and working and lose track
of time so for every time I get through
a 25-minute session I take a five minute
break after four sessions I take a ten
minute break which is the long gray
and during that time I can check my
email I check Twitter you know get up
and walk around so often times that'll
be a nice break for me to just evaluate
like is what I'm doing right now the
most important thing I could be doing
should I switch to something else like
just gives my brain a break and I
noticed when I don't do that I can they
get stuck on one problem for hours and
hours and not get anywhere and sometimes
I shouldn't worried about that problem I
should have just let it go and moved on
but since I never really stopped to
think about it I don't make that
decision so this is a really nice way of
doing things and I know I've seen
actually a lot of people use this and
there's even a one of the free code camp
challenges is to make your own Pomodoro
clock I haven't gotten to that challenge
yet so I am still working through my
free code camp front-end certification
it's actually I'm gonna do here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do my short break
and then I know if this time is up then
I should probably get back to coding
again our likeness this I'm gonna try to
remember this from now on we're gonna do
Pomodoro sessions and we're gonna try to
stick to during the session we code and
then during the break we talk and that
might be a more that'll be a nicer flow
for things and then it'll let you all
know like what's coming yeah I like that
idea let me know if you think about that
I think it should it should work but has
anybody made the Pomodoro timer and the
free code camp thing right now I'm
working on my well I should say I
finished working on my weather my
weather thing my weather app but I
didn't I didn't move on like I didn't
end in a link to
anything because I was gonna style it
but functionally it can it works it
works fine I just haven't done any
anything to style it yet and I built it
in reacts all right so I'm gonna check
out
okay so it looks like Sebastian also is
verifying that chrome and edge or white
for that talking about this this
drop-down is it's all white and you
can't see anything on chrome and edge
for for Windows so I have to work on
that
oh yes Patrick you're my hero today
alright so a few minutes ago I had asked
about these desktops being rearranged
automatically and I don't want that to
happen so Patrick just sent me
instructions on how to do this so I'll
do it on this screen so in case you've
ever had a similar problem we have
System Preferences and Mission Control
and uncheck oh wow that's really obvious
so I even asked that everybody I should
have just I should have just checked so
we'll uncheck that and then that will
fix the problem
awesome I'm actually I was like a
Windows user for my entire life until I
got this job and I've been working here
for almost two years so I've only been a
Mac user for about two years less than
two years so still don't really know
enough and and actually I come way
behind because Windows 10 like I haven't
really used Windows 10 that much so I
don't know what's going on there so I
feel like I'm not really an expert in
any operating system like if you like
put me in front of a Windows XP computer
then I would be fine I can do anything
you want me to do but right now I am NOT
not an expert at any operating system
oh cool
so Patrick actually like look that up
and figured it out because that annoyed
him as well so awesome Thank You Patrick
thanks for taking the time to do that
okay Vlad says it's a really interesting
way to keep track and make sure you're
working smart I may steal the process
from you yeah feel free to steal it for
me I took it from somebody else
so I definitely did not invent this I
did a course on Pluralsight because I
got a free like three months
subscription to Flora site and there was
a course on using agile methodologies
for one
so usually agile was used for teams well
I pretty much work just myself on all my
projects so I thought it sounded really
cool and I took the course and part of
the course was talking about the
Pomodoro timer and so that's where I
picked that up from and I thought I'd
give it a trial and use it for a few
weeks and see how I liked it and that
was last year and I've liked it so much
I've continued to use it for for all my
my projects occasionally I'll do a
little side project where I won't use it
but sometimes even on side projects I I
still use it because it's still a good
idea to you know break up the work like
that
okay Sara says she's on the jQuery part
now for free code camp so cool yeah that
would be cool if you all are doing the
free code camp stuff too it would be fun
to know what what part you all are on so
if you're in the live chat right now and
you can type go ahead and type if you
feel like sharing of like about where
you're at and if you're watching this
later on you put it in the comments
that'd be really cool just to get an
idea of where we're all at if if if you
are doing the free code camp challenges
I had a question about the Trello Adams
so actually so my my time here for my
short break is up so I'm just gonna
answer this last question and then get
back to the code the question was about
the Trello add-ons that I'm using with
the Pomodoro Technique
so yeah that's a great question let me I
believe that this is actually a Chrome
extension so let me see let's assume my
extensions are okay so here are my
extensions I'm gonna [ __ ] make this
bigger yeah okay so where's that
there we go so the extension is called
scrum for Trello so I think that's it I
think on a previous livestream I may
have said that it was a Trello add-on
but I think I was mistaken so I
apologize if anybody tried to add this
in Trello and couldn't find the add-on
but then later on I I realized that it
was an extension and I had meant to
mention it in a stream after that and
then I forgot until now so so that's
really cool while I'm in here my
extensions I'll show you this is a
really useful extension this tells me
like how what websites are built on so
I'm constantly using this when I see a
website that I like or one that's really
terrible and I just want to see like
what what do they build this with yeah
this is Michael tampermonkey is the one
that you need to make the colors on
github change so react dev tools is how
I get the react stuff in the in from
developer tools and something what else
all the JSON format err definitely
recommend that if you want to check out
JSON data that's why when I look at the
data from the WordPress API it looks
nice and not all jumbled and I think
that's it for like developer stuff
browsers that local I've actually never
used this I download this and I never
used it at all so I can't really say
whether it's good or not and then
retired j/s is kind of cool you can see
if there's any vulnerable JavaScript
libraries being used on any of your
sites it's not bad but I found like 99%
of the time it just shows like some
version of jQuery as being vulnerable
which which is ok but it's not like that
useful because if everybody is using
this same vulnerable version like I
don't I don't know like there's got to
be some version of jQuery that's not
vulnerable but it seems like everybody
that's using jQuery
it shows up as vulnerable so anyway
hopefully that was a little bit helpful
can't believe I never thought of showing
that before because I use those really
often so you can see this is that
analyzer here it's telling me that
Trello was built with jQuery they're
using Quantcast for analytics and Google
tag manager and Google Analytics so this
is actually this is crazy
I wouldn't guest:i if I were to guess
that I thought Trello was built with
some sort of like JavaScript framework
but it's it's actually just all jQuery
crazy I've been surprised to see how
many sites are built with react now that
I didn't realize her built with react so
which one was I was on GoDaddy recently
and GoDaddy site is now built with react
that was a little surprising Wow okay so
the song you guys remember the song
Mmmbop from the 90s from by a Hansen
that just came on I'm definitely gonna
skip that it's nostalgic but not not
really the song I want to listen to
okay so let me get back to the code now
I did ask a question and I'm getting
answers in the live chat I'll read them
off really quick it's not really polite
to ask a question and then ignore the
answers oh cool so Patrick has done the
Pomodoro thing and actually put a link
to it in the live chat so I'm gonna
check it out and while that's loading
yeah
that's nachiket says join the camp only
a day ago and have reached only till
bootstrap also well you got a good start
good start keep doing keep going and
keep us updated on how it goes inside
the matrix is on the twitch API projects
about halfway done with it also gave
your Pomodoro a heart Patrick all right
cool it oh okay so here's Patrick's
Pomodoro nice
I like that okay
oh so it automatically takes you into
the break interesting that's cool we can
double click to reset that's really cool
I'm gonna check out the code to this
later on that's awesome yeah thanks for
uh thanks for sharing that link
hey Andrew so Andrew joining us welcome
glad you can make it inside the matrix
says I've been listening in 90s rock
such alternative on Pandora lately so
many middle-school memories yeah we must
be a brown the same age because that's I
was in grade school in Middle School in
the 90s as well so it's always it's
always fun to listen to the old music
and then just have all these memories
come up
Manny says it would be cool to link the
timer to the Trello board and have it
forcefully limit how much time you can
spend on each feature I think it would
increase productivity man he also says
90s for the best hey Manny I'm not I'm
not sure if I've seen you post in the
live chat before so I may be mistaken
but if this is your first time posting
then welcome and thanks for contributing
here in the live chat yeah Manny that's
like a really really good idea I'm not
sure how I would accomplish that but I
think that would be a really cool side
project
okay jonbi says hi hi again hey how's it
going glad you could make it alright so
let me go back I spent a lot more time
so that the Pomodoro timer only really
is effective if you if you pay attention
to it and actually stop working or start
working when you're supposed to that's a
top tip for me you have to be
disciplined about it alright so now
we're back on our homepage we're getting
the data that we need so now all we have
to do is render that data in the right
places so okay I was thinking that
where's all their stuff that I forgot
it's down the bottom because this is the
alternate version of the homepage that
will end up being the new version all
right so this is where we're gonna put
our the data from our quote so I need to
figure out what the what the slug is for
that so let me do that you find the slug
pretty sure it as the word quote in it
maybe it doesn't I have to bring up the
the actual WordPress and bring it over
let's see oh I didn't even call it quote
I called it home black banner instead of
quote banner so I guess that works
yeah that it works because we're not
we're not actually using a quote in
there before it used to be a quote and
now it's the mission statement so this
yeah this actually does describe what it
is
so I'm assuming that that's the yeah
that's the [ __ ] we need okay so we're
gonna grab and we'll need to change this
as well because we're not this is the
the old information that was there okay
so I know I was going to copy copy this
to make it easier
I should copy I have a similar section
on the about page so I will copy the
section that most closely matches it I
think it's up
up here
here it is
so I'm a copy and paste but then I'll go
through what it does mmm this is
actually a little bit different because
we have this h3 but it is inside the
block how are you gonna do this
okay I think maybe we can do this so I'm
gonna change it up a little bit so this
is still gonna be we're still gonna have
this blockquote like we do here but I
want to have
well actually is that why they're
automatically make it a div I think I
figured out why it wasn't formatting
properly I didn't realize that it
happened so that's cool I might have
fixed this just by this and I won't have
to worry about it again so let's check
this out rearrange this
[Music]
because this will be good if this works
now then that'll save me a bit of time
anybody remember Lauryn Hill from the
90s just just had Lauryn Hill come along
Spotify if you'd like to follow along
with my playlist as well check out the
throwback Thursday playlist on Spotify
nice alright so that was the issue with
the formatting so awesome so I
inadvertently figured that out as always
this is fun alright so let's I still
need to do it alter this just a bit well
I mean I need to make this home and
[Music]
inside of the block quote we're gonna
have an h3 and the h3
is going to have the title wait no it
won't because we have a title already
we already have it site or the title is
the home black banner okay so we can't
do it like that
but since WordPress already has a way to
make things like an H tag without having
to deal with the code then I'm okay with
leaving it like that so I think we can
safely just bring in everything
including that that H tag and it should
be pretty obvious to whoever is is
updating it that it should work so I'm
gonna copy this paste it in here and
make sure see that's an h3 so it's
already you know it's easy and WordPress
to make that in h3 and let's check out
the code really quickly so h3 I didn't
realize when I copied it over it grabbed
that I don't want that to stay that
could cause problems
I may have to double check and make sure
that it didn't do it with other things
as well okay so we'll update that so we
can get there the correct data in there
and then now we'll get rid of this block
load
and oops we need to make sure we close
that I'm not worried about the
formatting says we'll have once we once
we commit this it will auto format it
for us but it looks like something is
making there we go
the highlighting was just weird but I
think that all right everything should
work now so save that let's make sure
okay so it's not bringing in everything
let's check it out
what happened did we not the update this
maybe it was just it was probably
keeping the that's really weird
that was the old data right maybe it's
just caching the old data
let's see
yeah for some reason that data is
getting you still cashed maybe refresh
maybe I need to log into WordPress again
it looks like
no I mean it looks fun that's all I'm
not gonna worry about it I mean the data
will update eventually usually it
updates pretty quickly but anyway we'll
check back in a few minutes the next
thing is we can pull in some stuff from
here and we may need to maybe to see I
don't know if I'll need to copy and
paste these myself or maybe Amy who
handles the content can do this I think
they'll probably be some additional
things and so we'll see I'm gonna worry
about it now but I do want to do the
code to be able to pull these in so that
they're not hard-coded
okay cool um I was thinking I'd have to
make a new component but it looks like I
already made one so glad about that
now I just check the live chat inside
the matrix says the Fugees yes the the
Fugees that's what I meant so I had I
was listening to Lauryn Hill song but it
probably was a Fuji song it's just
Lauryn Hill does most of the singing
let's see
I just saw a couple of things in the
live chat right now so I'm gonna check
it really quick I'm gonna read it out
really quick I can see if a few of you
remember the Lauren Hill and Fuji song
so yeah definitely good songs Jordan
asked would it would I miss today we
haven't really got that much done today
we just kind of went over some of the
fixes that I did for some things that
were going wrong yesterday and we're
just kind of gradually going through and
taking a lot of this content that has
kind of been hard-coded in and we're
instead pulling it from the WordPress
API because I would like as much of the
site as possible to be editable in
WordPress yes Ellie thanks for thanks
for asking about the code editor it is
Adam so I love it when people ask me
about the editor the the theme is the
steady theme SCT I also Ellie I don't
think that I've seen you in the chat
before so welcome sorry if this is not
your first time and I just don't
remember but welcome to the live chat
Manny says sorry I'm late to the party
here but did you scrape some content
into the JSON I noticed that the quote
had tags on the JSON object and I
haven't seen that before
yeah
[Music]
let me see
let me make sure I know exactly what
you're referring to let's see and I'm
pretty sure you're referring about the
JSON that we saw here and let's find it
so are you talking about like the HTML
tags that are showing up here in if that
case if that is true then yeah we are
we're getting this content out of
WordPress the wordpress api and for the
content fields you actually do get all
the HTML that's included in those fields
as well and it comes through with the
json that's why we had to set it with
dangerously set enter HTML because up
here so that the tags actually rendered
as HTML tags instead of just being
printed out on the screen
because we wouldn't want to see we
wouldn't want to see those tags
displayed on the screen we want them to
be actually evaluated you know by the
browser
well Jeremy has got an interview
tomorrow
so it says thanks for the advice awesome
really really happy for you so you'll
have to let us know how the interview
goes hope maybe if the interview is
early enough tomorrow would you be able
to let us know in tomorrow afternoon's
livestream that would be really cool
otherwise they can wait till next week
but I'm excited so I want to know how it
goes haha jonbi says one of these days
you should just switch to a different
editor just to mess with us actually I
love so jahnvi I have an uncle who
everybody calls him John be even like
his kids call him call him John B or
Johnny B sometimes so I I think every
time I I see that name and say it there
I always think of him
all right so let's get back to this and
we have a lot done already since we
already have these cards made so all we
need to do is put some data in there and
we'll need C in this case we do we are
gonna iterate over the column as well or
we want to keep printing the column so
we'll go at this point and let's see for
a second I thought about doing a similar
thing to what we had done on the
resources page where you know we have
all these different tabs and we're doing
some pretty fancy stuff that I think it
was fabian had submitted a pull request
and did some cool stuff with the tabs
and how that gets rendered out but since
it's such a small amount of data I think
we're fine just to actually render out
the things for the for the tabs just
right off the bat for both tabs so I
think that should work and I don't think
it warrants trying to pull in the code
from the resources page and replicate
what's going on there so for this one
we're just going to just do really
simply this for our data and we want to
filter so everything needs to be
filtered since we're pulling in these
this big chunk of data that has multiple
post types
so the first filter we need to put on it
is going to filter for the post type so
we're gonna do post post type and we
want the type that equals post
and loose equals post and then after
that we're going to do filter it further
and we want the post that's gonna have
the post a CF type of what is this one
announcement and let me check let me
check to make sure that that's the value
we want yep announcement okay great and
the other one is I think news right so
our tights for getting announcement in
news great
okay so announcement and then after
we've done that then we can map and go
through everything so we're gonna post
and for we're gonna grab all of this
and on here we're gonna add a key and
the key is gonna be our post ID whoops
to put that in brackets if you're not
familiar with react anything that you
put in brackets inside your JSX which is
basically this HTML looking stuff here
that ends up it's JavaScript it's
evaluated as JavaScript so that's why
we're pulling in data and putting it in
brackets like this okay so our title is
going to be post oops
title and our content
our content is going to be post content
rendered and actually I need to put
render it up here too
and the the reason these all have to be
worded like this this is this is just
how it comes out from the WordPress API
and then for the URL it's going to be I
think it's just I'm gonna double check
that though all right so let's see
oh we call it link
now we didn't that's not it that would
be the link for WordPress we don't want
that link we want I hope we made a field
for this because we need it otherwise
you're gonna have to make one now
mmm well that's no good I'm gonna
double-check
let's check out what it looks like in in
WordPress so we have news if I see a
description slug and we didn't put in
anything for URL so let's make that post
right now we'll make that that field no
wait a second I remember why we didn't
do it now okay because we want these to
link to the actual blog post page
originally some of them were gonna link
to external resources but I don't think
we want to do that now we want to we
want this to work just like a regular
blog so it's gonna link to a blog page
alright so forget everything that I was
just saying I've lost my mind for a
second okay
so wish that we're good so the URL then
becomes
let's see do we want to put this
we don't really need the URL we need the
slug let me check out the I want to
check out this component just to see how
what we're doing with that inside the
component
okay
all right so then what we're gonna do is
build the URL here and pass the complete
URL in there because inside of here
you know we're checking for a blank URL
we're checking if so we're actually not
gonna lame
this is probably gonna be unnecessarily
Vitt in here just for now just in case
but it'll probably unnecessary to check
for a blank link because the way we're
gonna do it there's never gonna be a
blank link but it's okay well no sense
in like refactoring in the middle of
this if I'm not a hundred percent sure
that I'm not gonna use that so for this
URL I want to make it I'm gonna use a
template literal and I'm gonna say slash
news and then so I can go back into
JavaScript inside my template literal we
need to put a dollar sign and then curly
brackets and so now we can put
JavaScript in and then I'm gonna say
post slug and that's gonna put together
that that URL will work because we're
using parameterised routing for anything
that's on the route of news so it'll
just pass the slug along to our template
for news which is our single news page
template and then it'll use that here it
will pass it along as ID so this is
really the slug it will use the slug
here to make the API call to get just
the data that it needs for that
particular post so we're good
alright so we should be able to save
that and I can delete the rest of these
and I got a Hootie and the Blowfish is
playing right now I totally forgot about
them I used to really like Hootie and
the Blowfish when I was in grade school
we can also copy this now and with only
one change use it down here
and all what i have to change is this
filter and then we can get rid of this
and let's save it and refresh restart my
search
it's getting worse it used to be that I
could code for a while without having to
restart my dev server and now it's like
very frequently oh man my timer ran out
I didn't even notice it all right well I
guess I'll start the showed up again
with the break let's go down here
whoa I'll shoot I had thought about that
and then I forgot so this I'm actually
kind of glad this has happened so this
is what happens if you don't dangerous
yet enter HTML when you're grabbing
stuff from WordPress content the tags
actually show up so you can see them
there and you can see here the tags are
showing up the good thing is what we did
worked and it is in fact filtering
things into the right spot and also good
news is we know exactly how to fix this
so let's do that now so we need to go
into our text card before since we were
manually typing in a string of what we
wanted these to be I had never bothered
with setting the inner HTML and probably
lazily because I always knew this was
eventually gonna be populated with other
data so I should have just done it
before but now we can just grab I'll
just grab this I don't even have to type
it out again
so for the title and the description we
want to do this for both of them so I'm
gonna put this on the title and on the
description and we're gonna change this
to this drops title and we're gonna
change
this one - this crops do we call it
content
I just want to double-check yes we did
call it content here this props content
okay now we can remove this okay we can
remove this and let's save it just to
make sure it works
whoa
all right this is I forgot that okay so
here's what's happening here in this
post I went to pages sorry
in this post there's an image I had done
this earlier when I was meeting with
with Amy who does the content just to
show her how to put an image in and I've
forgotten about it but what we want to
do is we actually don't want that image
to show up so here's what I think I
think we only want the excerpt to show
up here we don't want the full text
because it could be really big like this
already extends out so let's let's
change this so what we want to do we
only have to change it here post excerpt
and now let's check out
wait a second let me check the check
this
I didn't think the excerpt kept images
Oh actually no I don't think I want to
keep the excerpt because it adds in this
more this more link I don't want that
and I know I can change this and the
function is a PHP file but I don't want
to go through all that so all right I'm
gonna go since I had already used up
most of my five minutes that I was gonna
spend on a live chat I'm gonna go to
lunch at now that will give us a minute
to think about the best way to address
this basically the problem is I don't
have enough space here here to put
everything so I need a way to just get
some of the data also I need to strip
out any images because I don't want
images in here
the simplest way seemed to be to get the
excerpt from WordPress instead of the
entire content but that's not gonna work
because of the more tag so potentially I
could use that and then just strip out
the more tag either on this end with
JavaScript or on the wordpress end with
PHP so I'm gonna go back to the live
chat and talk for a little bit with you
all when we can all think about what the
best way to do that is
okay I did get a Sarah asked if I'd
tried Visual Studio code yeah I have
tried Visual Studio code I was using it
actually used it on some of my earliest
live streams so the ones I did on my own
channel before I got invited to stream
for free code camp I was using visual
studio code on some of those so if you
actually want to see me using Visual
Studio code go check out some of my my
first live streams the I will warn you
though the first couple of streams are a
little bit rough because the quality I
didn't I didn't really have the hang of
using OBS yet to do my streaming so the
quality is not great and there were some
streams where I had no one watching so
it's just me talking no interaction with
anyone but you will get to see me use
Visual Studio code so I think the
project I'll be working on after I
switched from this one which will be
like at the end of next week I think I'm
gonna switch back to the project that
was working on so I'll probably be
switching back to Visual Studio code the
reason I use Visual Studio code for that
project is because a lot of it is
written in c-sharp and when I tried to
load c-sharp and Adam it didn't
automatically highlight things for me
but when I loaded it in Visual Studio
code it did highlight things really
nicely so instead of getting the right
plug-in for Adam I just used Visual
Studio code because that was that was
faster and I had been looking for an
excuse to try it out anyway and so it
was good I I liked it I'm not ready to
switch from Adam but I do like it
a new path says hi hey how's it going
Ali says hi Sabir says hi hey everyone
thanks for joining in wow this would
already it's already 6 o'clock Wow hey I
just checked my phone so a man at 6
o'clock I wonder for my wife's tried to
call me she did not try to call me but
she did ask me in the text do you know
what happened to the sweet Italian
sausages and no I don't know what
happened to them I hope the dog didn't
eat them we recently got a dog against
my against my will
we got a dog and basically I didn't want
a dog because there are a lot of work
and I knew that I would probably be
doing a lot of the work and I knew that
I would fall in love with the dog and
there was a good chance that we wouldn't
be able to keep the dog because the last
time my wife wanted a dog it didn't get
along with the kids and so we had to get
rid of it it broke my heart so I didn't
want my heart broken again but she
brought on this dog and the dog loves me
sorry for the little tangent but there
was no questions in the live chat so I
thought I'd just say it so the dog loves
me and wants to be around me all the
time and the dog hated my wife which was
kind of funny because she's the one that
really wanted a dog so the dog I mean
literally that that if the dog was
eating and my wife walked into the room
the dog would leave the room wait for my
wife to leave and then come back in and
resume eating so I did feel bad for my
wife because she really wanted that dog
so the dog in my wife now get along but
now my wife thinks that she's allergic
to the dog so I think we're gonna end up
getting rid of the dog I feel really bad
for the dog because it just changed
homes to us and now it's gonna change
again and so anyway and then I'm gonna
miss the dog so anyway the whole reason
I even get onto that is
the dog's been eating food off the table
so if one of the kids has like a
hamburger or something and leaves it on
the table and goes in the other room
when they come back in the room the
hamburger is missing and the plate is
clean it's because the dog eats eats all
their stuff so now I'm gonna check the
live chat really quick and then I'll get
back to to what we were doing we'll
figure out a solution to our little
problem as youngbae said yeah blame it
on the dog Jesse it's true I didn't he I
only ate one sausage I didn't eat all of
them
Wow Sebastian scissors after midnight
where you were you from Sebastian you
probably told me before and I just don't
remember
alright okay I did have some other
questions come in the live chat while I
was telling a story about my dog
so Jambi yes how long did it take you to
learn react and basically anything I
really didn't pay that much attention to
react until last May so I went to a
conference last May and everybody was
talking about react and so that's what I
really like seriously started thinking
like that I need to learn about react
because it looks cool I had like I had
heard of react before then but my
attitude was kind of like oh man another
JavaScript framework like well we'll see
we'll see if this one is sticks around
you know because there's so many
frameworks right so basically it's been
about a year I haven't I didn't really
try to build anything in react until
probably like January or May so it
wasn't until this year that I actually
tried to build something in react I had
done some tutorials in react before so I
had watched some video tutorials I did
the Khan Academy a tutorial for react
but I hadn't really successfully built
anything until until this this year so
sometime in in the early months of 2017
I started like seriously starting to
build things and learn more about react
so I the first react site that I ever
launched like for a client I launched it
on April 1st of 2017 so that was my
first successful site and so it hasn't
really been that long it's kind of
surprising now that I think about it
that I've I'm building site so when I
say like that I really had consider
myself to be very new and still learning
react like really it hasn't
that long so I'm definitely not an
expert at it
Oh Jeremy's got a see you later Jeremy
Jeremy says it's got to go
thanks for the videos I'll let you know
how my interview goes tomorrow if I
catch it all right awesome
yeah definitely want to hear about the
interview good luck with that and yeah
and thanks thanks for watching
let me check I'm going to take a few
more questions
well Sebastian said you can add an
excerpt field in WordPress so whoever
adds the post can add a little excerpt
with no image and then use the real post
for the blog post yeah I can oh I'm
gonna think about that I got to think
I'm not sure if I want I can see pros
and cons to that so definitely it would
be cool for the content editors to be
able to say exactly what they won on the
front but it would also be a little bit
of extra work I guess they could just
copy and paste like the first paragraph
if they really wanted to
so we'll see maybe maybe although that
is I kind of like that I do you know and
I think about it more that might be the
best solution here
sir-sir guala says it's five where I'm
located cool does that mean like 5:00
a.m. or 5:00 p.m. if it's 5 p.m. then
you're probably pretty close to my
timezone if it's 5 a.m. then you you're
probably on the other side of the world
I encourage says it's 3:30 5:00 a.m.
here in India okay cool yeah I mean I
usually remember what time it is in
India because I've had who is it Rohan
always tells me what time it is in India
so Rohan must have been asleep for this
one usually he stays up to like 2:00
a.m. India time and I don't know how he
does it and on couch how are you up at
3:35 a.m. watching this I'm glad I'm
glad you're watching this thanks for
watching but that's crazy all right
Sebastian has a cat sitting on his lap
right at the moment it's really hot in
the house and the hairy cat is not
helping yeah is it you know like pets
pets and kids always want to like be
right next to you when it's hot and like
my son my oldest son Raphael like when I
go to put him to sleep at night like
he'll cuddle up next to me and we'll
read a book or something and he'll say
like oh I'm so hot and I'm like dude
just like you're you're like on top of
me you know you can't just scoot over a
little bit it's not that I don't you
know I don't want to cuddle with him but
it's like doesn't help if the body heat
is being shared okay Sebastian you're
Spain all right awesome
oh it's about Sebastian Asif if I saw
what he said about what I asked yeah uh
obviously I saw that now so I think that
is a good idea and I'm probably gonna go
with that dyad asks what do you think
about the UJS I haven't used UJ s and I
haven't learned enough about it to have
a good opinion on it so I'm not gonna
try to give you an answer that I would
just make up what I will say is that
I've seen a lot of people talk about it
on Twitter so I mean it seems legit just
from like the amount of buzz this
getting and amount of hype on Twitter
and the people that are like legitimate
programmers who are using it and saying
it's good so I can't say firsthand
anything about it but it does seem like
it's a legitimate alternative framework
Andrew said I started at work to make an
admin dashboard and react and react
router and fell in love with it that's
awesome
I'd like to see that I don't know if
you're able to share that share a coder
there any anything with that or a link
but that would be really cool to see
Andrew John B says I gotta head out
myself to hope you all have a good day
have a good day Jesse and see you again
sometime soon
all right see you John B probably
already left so I didn't read that fast
enough but in case you're still here see
you thanks for joining and contributing
in a live chat really appreciate that on
couche says I just came in what's the
problem we were having okay so here's
the problem he came in so basically you
can see on the screen it's pulling in
I'm pulling in some data but it's
pulling in like an image and stuff and I
don't want that I basically just want a
little bit of text like the first bit of
text so I think the solution we're gonna
do is I'm gonna make another field for
this post
so I'll have another field probably up
here down here somewhere
that's just going to be for the the
excerpt right so the content editor is
going to type in just a little bit and
that's
here here and then the real content will
appear after you click it will take you
to another page and show it all Alberto
says without giving it too much thought
add a style for the card image to
display none yeah actually that's a
really good idea that would that would
solve the image thing it still wouldn't
solve the problem of trying to pool like
all the the content but that's a really
good idea for like a simple fix okay let
me get back to this now that we've we've
kind of decided on a solution let's do
this I'm gonna make I know that there's
an excerpt field that you can add that's
like kind of by default comes in
WordPress but I'm not going to use that
one because I don't know I don't think
that'll automatically strip out the tags
and I want all the tags stripped out for
this part because I don't want people
putting like an unordered list or
something crazy in here that's gonna
throw off my formatting so I'm gonna use
the custom fields plug-in to make a
field I already have the posts field and
I'm just gonna add excerpt and the other
cool thing I can do with this is that I
can put explanatory text so let me make
this a text area and I can also limit
the characters so let me think how many
characters would probably fit there
there's anybody good with estimating
characters so I wanted to fill up I mean
it can go all the way down to here but I
don't want it any any more so I wonder
if I have all right
this is about 30 characters across okay
so 300 I'm gonna set a three hundred
character limit because it's about 30
characters across and I'm pretty sure I
could get at least ten lines on here so
30 or 300 character limit
and for the formatting I'm gonna say no
formatting so it's not gonna pull in any
of the HTML tags for the instructions
I'm gonna say
give a little bit of instruction and
it's just going to be required yes this
will be required we need this otherwise
we'll get nothing on here and that
that'll be no good so not all the posts
will appear here I'm just gonna grab the
newest post so I won't actually need
this for all of them but at some point
probably every post will appear here
unless unless like more than four posts
get added all at the same time all right
I'm gonna double check make sure I
filled everything in and all right that
looks good so let's update and I'm gonna
go back to posts and I'm just gonna fill
in some of this data so we have
something excerpt and I'm gonna grab
some lorem ipsum text or maybe I use
bacon if some yesterday of the day
before
what's your favorite lorem ipsum
generator I know I've seen a generator
for samuel l.jackson it's just like
Samuel Epson we could try to use that
there's like a
there's a generator that uses all like
the bad language versions of it and then
I think there's another one that just
has the quotes that that don't have bad
language in it so I think we'll use the
stuff without the bad language
I
I gotta read the quotes first since I'm
not you know this is a site for the
University I sure don't put it anything
crazy up here but this is a quote I
think from the movie unbreakable I
believe so
this will this should work I do want to
test out
okay so cool so this did work so we have
we stopped at 300 characters so that
would definitely work out to give us an
idea of how much the 300 characters are
so let me update this and I need to
update our code because we're grabbing
the excerpts from the ACF field now and
we might end up getting an error I'm
just going to try but we'll probably end
up getting an error because this field
is not going to exist for the some of
the posts right now we save not actually
safe I just need to restart the dev
server
hmm
well
actually this is odd we're still if you
notice like this is still the old data
and nothing is nothing is updating I
don't like that that's really weird
wow this is so I haven't blocked this
off so that it doesn't display anything
this is what the site would look like
it's not too bad but it's still showing
okay now that is the right data that is
still showing why is it not pulling in
what we just did right content imposed a
CFX oh yeah what's going on
that's weird
oops I was looking for content I meant
excerpt
here we go
ACF excerpts all right so it's here we
see it here
okay so what's going on here
yeah I'm thinking maybe it is the cash
so Sebastian just said cash but the
other thing is like I'm not there
shouldn't be any cash when I'm running
the dev server so I have it set so that
the the cash is like one second or
something so that shouldn't be the issue
and then I haven't set up a cash for the
WordPress API and obviously like we're
getting the new data in the API as well
actually I want to add a new post to
okay
so you check that out so we got this so
it's not an API caching thing but
potentially like I guess it could be
trying to pull in most ACS excellent
are we caching
you check my server Dutch AS VAL to make
sure i'm not cashing anyone so yeah so
it should be yeah so the cache time it
looks like I've set it to 100
milliseconds
yeah so that that looks like it's set up
fine
okay so let's open up getting some
requests to open up dev tools let's see
I think I have it automatically set to
disable the cache if dev tools are open
so let's see if that fixed it just from
being open no but it did freeze my desk
for her again
alright so we'll start that up again
with dev tools open
this is one of those unexpected
slowdowns that I was worried about let
me make sure that I have the cash
disabled
I can't remember where that what that is
anybody remember where that option is in
dev tools
should I read through all the ones make
sure I'm not missing it
maybe it's somewhere else let me check
oh that's in the network tab okay sorry
I wasn't looking over there yeah okay
cool I did have disabled cash checks I
thought I always did keep that off
it's such a huge here's what's weird to
me so we've definitely now I know what
happened man if you haven't already
figured it out oh I feel so silly now
okay so we only changed it here right
our this is behaving exactly as we told
it to behave because it's still being
told to pull the content rendered for
the announcements oh man
see this there we go that's what we need
all right that's it and that's pretty
much perfect as far as the length goes
we could increase it a bit
so I can maybe go like three owner we
could probably fit another line in there
I don't want it to look too crowded at
the bottom so maybe I can go like two
320 characters who ever really wanted to
but I don't think that's a big deal
we'll see if that's really something
that's necessary I can increase it a bit
okay so so this works and actually the
cool thing is I wasn't getting errors I
was I was thinking I may get an error
because that field wouldn't exist at all
in ACF but it seems like we're not
getting the error at least it's not
causing it man these things are coming
from looks like we're not giving
something in it a key somewhere so we
need to figure out what's not getting
the key and they say Oh since you won 34
in the blockquote that's weird because
we're we're only pulling one thing maybe
it still wants a key even though it's
one thing so we give that a key these
are caused by the YouTube embed so the
YouTube embed seems to be working so I
guess I'm not gonna worry about these is
there any special thing that needs to
happen with YouTube embeds and react
that's gonna mess up the site if so you
know about it
please let me know otherwise I'll just
kind of let it go and make sure that I
test out that homepage on different
browsers so let's put in the key and
wish do like we've been doing and say
post id loose post id
and we can check to make sure I guess I
didn't refresh
great okay so we don't have that error
anymore oh so let's I'm just going to go
ahead so we've been working on this for
a while and how long were you doing this
I have at least done probably four
Pomodoro sessions so far I've been
streaming for what like two hours I want
to say at least three or four I'm gonna
say I've done three more sessions so I'm
gonna bump that up to six because I have
done some a little bit of talking so
three sessions I'm glad that I estimated
it at 13 because I'll probably need most
of that time although we as we run into
and figure out you know some of these
issues it'll make each successive page a
bit easier but anyway a home page just
looking at looking decent now so this is
everything that we wanted to do for the
home page well with the exception of
this what the heck is going on with this
let's double check let's check this
again for some reason
oh you know what why is this a quote
let's change this so I think I put
I think I took out the normal editor and
I put in this custom field here and
that's probably what's messing things up
because the original data probably had
this in it and nothing else
yeah so that's what's go into our custom
fields and yep home barriner fields and
we had the quote in alright so let's
let's just get rid of that because I
don't think we need yeah we don't need
that this should work without it better
to just simplify it if we don't need it
now let's go back to the pages we'll see
what's going on
and if I'm correct yep there we go so
once again it's doing exactly what we
told it to do I was just confused about
what I was telling it to do so let me
grab
what I have it I still have the
development server open which does have
the text that I want so I'll grab it
from there here and then let's make sure
yeah I want to get rid of that data JSX
cuz that'll mess things up and update
now we'll be able to see what it really
looks like and if it's it's gonna look
how we want it to look
man this dev server is like stopping so
often it might be faster to just not
have hot module reloading and manually
refresh the page alright cool so this is
working this is how we wanted it to look
awesome
so that's the home page done and I
forgot to start up my my timer again
no let's I'm gonna commit this
check out the status okay so we've
edited what do we do the about I don't
remember what we did to the about page
it's probably just some sort of Auto
formatting thing that that happened so
I'm not gonna worry about it Oh
[Music]
enough to remember to push all these
changes to the the dev server so you all
can see this I'll try to remember to do
that before I leave today okay so we've
got the home page getting the data that
we want from the API I'm gonna check the
live chat and then I'm have to decide
whether I want to keep working or go
home since it's after 6:30 p.m. my time
so it's definitely beyond the point at
which I normally go home I've been here
since 9:30 a.m. and I worked through my
lunch break alright so I'm gonna scroll
up a bit so you see what I missed
okay Sara showed there's a Bible Epsom
Oh seriously that that would actually be
perfect for this site I'm gonna look
that up on my other screen that would be
way more appropriate than Samuel Jackson
Epsom for this site like I wouldn't mind
it for like a side project but oh really
cool awesome
all right cool I'm definitely gonna use
the Bible if some now when I need lorem
ipsum text the rest of the site I think
the people who are in charge of
catechetical Institute would appreciate
that much more than the samuel l.jackson
or even the bacon ipsum as awesome as
that is okay it looks like some of you
were asking about like to see things in
dev tools and stuff but I think that was
in reference to the problem we're having
and sorted that all out it was basically
just my fault and not changing what I
needed to change so birdperson asked and
this was maybe 20 minutes ago so sorry
for getting back to you a little later
but very person as Jesse can you advise
starting point to study react what you
read watch Thanks so my advice would be
to watch just to get an idea of like the
the whole philosophy behind react
there's some videos you can watch from
like the react conf like Facebook's
react conference what do they call is it
just called react conf I can't remember
now but if you check out the react like
the Facebook developers YouTube or
something I can't remember what it is
now what the YouTube channel is for sure
but check out like some of the keynote
addresses where they explain the
reasoning behind it that's kind of cool
you don't need to know that to know
react but it's kind of cool to get in
the mindset of like why why even make
another framework you know what's this
for so that's kind of cool some of the
talks will be like way over your head
some of the socks are still over my head
so you know probably don't need to watch
them all there's some stuff about react
on will stern has a YouTube channel
called learn code
Academy I think that's that's what is
called so he has some react stuff that's
good the videos are a little bit older
but they still work for an introduction
to react the react documentation on like
the official react website is pretty
good code Academy has like an in-browser
react tutorial that you can go through
this kind of nice because you don't need
to know how to set up any development
environments so that will be helpful and
I think what else free code camp I
haven't checked out the react section in
a while I'm not sure that the react
section is actually finished for like
the the official courses right now the
official challenges but the beta version
of the challenges I think has more react
stuff in it I I haven't checked that in
a while so I can't say for sure so that
those resources are what I would
probably check out I think you could
probably get some idea of what's going
on and react from some of my past
streams but my streams aren't exactly
like a tutorial so that might be useful
like if you were working on something
else and just wanted to play it in the
background and just like watch when
something was happening that was useful
that might be it might be helpful to you
otherwise like it wouldn't be really
efficient to try to watch my streams to
actually learn anything because there's
so much other stuff going on that it's
not focused enough so you'll you will
probably learn stuff but it'll be all
over the place most of the time and the
streams are brief can be really long so
anyway I hope at least some of those
resources are helpful to you and all
right also I recommend starting out with
something like an XJS or create react
app just to help you get started
building something oh also too if if you
if you have money to spend on trying
to learn react Udacity has a good react
course they just started and I'm I'm
taking the course right now and I've
been impressed with it so far but the
course is 500 dollars like so like in US
dollars it's 500 dollars
so not sure you know how much you want
to spend on react but that that course
has been good so far from me
let's see okay it looks like Andrew sent
an image I'm assuming this is of the
admin panel that you made in react we'll
find out in a second I'm going to open
up on my other screen here and just say
oops I say I think I put left this space
in there
there we go that's weird
so anyway Andrew I tried to check out
that image and it's it's giving me the
error the error page for imager so Sara
said in response to bird person's
question about react the try level up
tux or level up I'm not sure how you
pronounce it it's level up to UTS which
is supposed to be short for tutorials
but I always look at it and want to say
level up tuts
and so I'm not sure how are you supposed
to pronounce it yeah okay thanks
everyone for trying to try to help out
with the air I was having I can see now
on the chat that you were all kind of
asking about it but sorry about the
silly mistake on my part
okay so Patrick had a link that looks
like it's gonna be useful so I'm gonna
open this on my other screen real quick
and if maybe I'll pull it over under my
main screen so I get why they don't let
you put links in the live chat but it
ends up being annoying to have to copy
and paste them and then take out the
spaces and stuff so anyway this is the
resource that patrick has just put in
the live chat for learning react so this
is the react redux length on github so
it looks like it has a lot of nice stuff
for getting started tutorials so nice
that's that's this looks really good
Patrick so thanks for this so this
should be helpful to anyone it looks
like to anyone starting out or at any
level of trying to learn react this is
really cool I'm definitely gonna star
this hey I already started cool does
that ever happen anyone else you find
this really awesome github repo and then
you go to start and you realize that
you've already started at some point I
need to go back and look through this
stuff I've starred I'm sure I'll find
useful stuff there that I've completely
forgotten about but this one looks good
it looks like it's it's kept up to date
like I mean look this two days ago it
was updated so that's cool sometimes you
see nice lists like this but they're a
little outdated but this one is kept up
so thanks Patrick
okay Sara also says for in terms of
react courses also if you don't mind
paying try West boss calm so yeah I've
never taken any courses from there I've
seen maybe on Twitter i'm not i don't
remember where I've seen it maybe an
advertisement or something for that so
but I can't really say personally
anything about it because I haven't
haven't taken any any courses okay
Sebastian says if you use map you need a
key so since I used earlier I was
getting the air that I needed a key but
it was even it was on this block quote
and I'm only pulling one thing for the
block but quote but since I was using
map I still needed the key which that
makes sense I don't mind putting the key
on there that will help me get used to
putting the key in there all the time
which I frequently forget to do so maybe
if I make myself do it enough times I'll
remember it
Sebastien says by the way you get the
solution to the warning in the warning
itself yeah I know usually react is
really good about providing really
useful warnings
thanks you wanna check that out now and
actually didn't read this frameborder oh
that's why thanks for saying that
Sebastian because now I realized that I
should have just read this oh man okay
so let's just fix this right now I feel
so so silly right now that I didn't just
take three seconds to actually read that
warning so basically in react it wants
me to camelcase this let me see what's
this when it wants allowfullscreen okay
wants me to camelcase these I gotten
lazy with this stuff because I have a
NPM module that actually lets me use
like class instead of class name and
things like that but I guess it doesn't
convert stuff like this let's see yeah
it looks like I think this is new stuff
here so it looks like it went away I I
do want to double check just want to see
that nice clean clean screen there yeah
all right check it out now we only have
I should get rid of this console log and
this console ugh
I'm gonna do that right now cuz
otherwise I'll forget I think that's in
analytic that's both in the analytics
okay so I don't need this and I don't
need this
that now we're those the heirs all right
those are the areas that I get when my
my dev server fails all right so next
time I see those errors I'm not just
gonna get rid of them actually gonna
read them and try to figure out what is
going on but at least I won't it won't
be quite so cluttered now that I've
gotten rid of some of the logs okay
Patrick says +14 west boss he's awesome
okay so maybe that that resources we got
two people in the live chat now
recommending that resource so maybe I'll
have to check it out I don't have time
to take on another course right now
since I'm already doing one well I'm
already doing free code camp and Udacity
on top of my other work and taking care
of all my kids so maybe when I finish up
with one of the things then I can do
check out west boss how's the pricing on
that is it like really expensive or you
know compared to a lot of other courses
okay Andrews asking about the Pomodoro
Technique and the stuff in Trello I
explained it like in more depth early in
the stream so if you can check out the
recording like you'll get a better
explanation but basically the numbers in
Trello or the number of Pomodoro
sessions that each task takes so a
Pomodoro session is 25 minutes so every
25 minutes I take a five-minute break
after four sessions I take a 10-minute
break it helps break up the work and it
helps to more accurately estimate the
time the tasks take so the the dark
numbers in Trello or how many Pomodoro
sessions I think it's going to take and
the lighter numbers are how many it
actually took me to do I see now that
Sara already answered Andrews it's
thanks there sorry I didn't see that I
was
anyway those those two cadets and
Patrick answered as well to man ten as
what software are you using for your dev
server basically it's just like it's web
pack but it I don't have to customize it
myself because next Jas is automatically
running it so that's part of the reason
why I haven't even dug into the issue
because I I didn't need to set it up
myself so I know like I'm gonna have to
learn how it was set up before I can
even try to fix it so but basically it
is web pack though Sebastian says I
think you have some more posts with data
- JSX I think you're right - because I
was copy and pasting earlier in the day
and I didn't remove that so I'm gonna
have to go back and double-check
everything
well Andrew says in my country for West
bust courses I get a 52% discount that's
sweet wit what country are you from
Andrew you probably told me before so
sorry I don't I don't remember but we'll
see if you if that 52% is a big discount
it might be worth moving for I'm just
joking it probably wouldn't be but maybe
if you're gonna take enough courses
Manny says have you tried fetching from
Component did mount and saving your data
in your app state object yeah I actually
do that on some of the pages some of the
components but the thing is with with
next J s you if you want it to be able
to render server-side you have to fetch
the data from in here from get initial
props so what I do if I want to put it
into state is I end up in component did
mount transferring the data into state
so I still grab it here and it still
goes to props first and then it goes
into state and then I can you know
manipulate the data use it after at that
point so on this page I really don't
have any need to save it the state
because I'm not like I don't ever need
to change it to make things rerender or
happen so but on on some pages like the
resource page I do I am doing that but
it still I still grab everything
initially with this get initial props
just for the sake of the server-side
rendering
okay Manny says you Demi's modern react
and redux is very awesome for starting
out a very awesome course so albury
person says thank you Jesse for the
advice you're welcome I hope some of it
is helpful to you and make sure like if
you can come back some other live chats
and let us know like how it's going and
what resources you found helpful I think
that would be awesome it'd be helpful
for me and I'm sure would probably be
helpful for some other people that are
that are watching Manny says learn a lot
from you awesome I'm glad I'm but glad
that I could be helpful a lot of times I
feel like I'm not really being helpful
to you all you are teaching me a lot so
it's nice when sometimes I I'm doing the
teaching a little bit all right so
Andrew posted the link again yeah me
maybe I thought I got rid of all the
spaces let me try it again
yeah it did work I must have just left
the space in there and didn't realize it
oh very cool
that's really cool Andrew I'm checking
out on my other screen I don't know if
you want me to show it to everybody in
the live stream or not so that's why I
open it on the other stream or the other
screen that's really cool I like that
yeah so if if anyone is sharing any of
their own work by default I will just
open it on another screen in case you
don't want everybody to be able to see
it in the stream you know and in the
recording but if you don't mind that
just let me know when you give me the
link and then I can as long as it's
appropriate if nobody's ever tried to
share anything inappropriate but as long
as it's appropriate I'll put it up there
that's also another reason why I open it
on a separate screen just on on the off
chance that someone would happen to post
something inappropriate actually that
link the Heroku link is it's not working
for me it's saying access denied for me
why is it saying what are Y saying
asketh access denied when I try to put
the link in okay I see you posted
another link a little a little bit after
okay ceressus 72 and 98 so I assume
that's in response to my question about
the pricing for for West boss and Manny
also recommends West boss okay that's
not too bad actually
oh yeah that's a decent price so 72
dollars 98 so it seems like West boss is
the way to go I might even have to check
that out I mean like I said I there's no
way I could do another course right now
but I'll keep that in mind for the
future okay Andrew says Moldova cool so
you're from so I have three three of my
wife's cousins were adopted from Moldova
so that's what I remember when they were
adopted they were just really little and
could barely speak English or anything
and I remember visiting with my wife's
and uncle and they live they live in a
different state so went down there and
stayed with them for like a week and
helped out with the kids and everything
it was cool when now the kids are like
they're teenagers so it makes me feel
old
but anyway that's cool and I I get I
know people from Moldova
okay rich Rishabh I'm not sure I
pronounce a so sorry
but rich a vas hey I just came to this
live video I want to know how we can
link [ __ ] with react I want to know
that suit actually says so in this video
I'm actually linking WordPress with
react through the WordPress API so I'm
not dealing with a database directly
there's like the WordPress API is
sitting between the database and it's a
different kind so I mean WordPress uses
a sequel database which is definitely
different than [ __ ] so at some point
it's likely that I will do something
that uses a [ __ ] database with react
but I can't I can't guarantee when that
project will happen so so I can't answer
your question right now unfortunately
but I hope that in the future I can do
more streams with with [ __ ] and react
okay see you later mani
mandis gotta head out thanks thanks for
watching I know you're contributing in
the latch at
Patrick says in response to the question
about [ __ ] DB says I would expect you
would want to write a back-end service
in something like no tour Express to
provide endpoints for interacting with
MongoDB yeah that's actually that's a
really good answer so I mean that would
be you know that wanting in specifics of
how you do that that I mean that would
be the way to go you obviously you
wouldn't be reacting like you wouldn't
be going directly from reacts like
client-side directly to a database most
likely you would have some sort of I get
would you call that a middleware I don't
know but but your back-end node Express
would be interacting with the database
and then sending that so
yes Sebastian says sorry about the
language change Sebastian just started
talking in another language in the live
chat or typing in another language
birdperson says thank you very much
Jessy I was glad to spent this time with
FCC campers jordan says shouldn't you be
going home Jessie yeah I should I was
just thinking the same thing so anyway
you're welcome birdperson so yeah I'm
glad you spent time with us as well so
yeah anyway I think I am gonna wrap it
up cuz it's 7:00 and I need to go home
and put my kids to sleep so yeah so I
kinda hope to get a little bit more done
but unfortunately I did have some silly
issues that came up and we're entirely
just my fault for not paying attention
more closely to my code so I need to
commit those last couple changes we made
to get rid of the errors and that's
about it I'm going to commit that I'm
going to push everything up to the dev
server and I might check the dev server
to make sure it does it quits just
shutting down and then that way at least
it'll be open to anyone who wants to see
it and then I'll I'll be here tomorrow
morning and I'll do some more work and
I'll see you all tomorrow I'm pretty
sure that I can do the stream at the
normal time tomorrow I have a meeting
with a potential client at 5:00 p.m. so
it won't be a super long stream but I
could probably do like an hour hour and
a half stream and still have enough time
to make it to the meeting so anyway it
was it was cool I'm glad I got to do
this and death see some different people
probably because of the different you
know time that I strained that so
tomorrow it'll be at the normal time
most likely 2 p.m. Eastern time thank
you so much everyone for watching and
for helping out and in the live chat is
really awesome and really cool just
working on this project you you all have
been like kind of with this project for
the whole
time you know pretty much from the
beginning so this is very much like I
think our project together and it's
really cool so I can't wait to like be
done with it and move on but then you
know have this entire project from start
to finish like all live-streamed I think
that's that's gonna be really cool so
anyway good night everybody at least in
my timezone good night and have a great
night I'll see y'all tomorrow